les pays alliés faisaient monter la
pression sur le Canada l'Allemagne puis
les États-Unis ont annoncé qu'ils
enverraient des chars de combat
14 chars d'assaut puent léopathe les
Américains
les quatre chars léopard 2 seront
envoyés en Ukraine au cours des
prochaines semaines ils seront
accompagnés de pièces de rechange et de
munitions des militaires canadiens
offriront aussi de la formation aux
soldats Ukrainiens
l'opération sera complexe les chars
seront livrés un à un par avion le
Canada aurait-il les moyens d'en faire
plus
notre flotte est petite en comparaison
avec celle des européennes appelle le
chef d'état-major de la Défense il
n'exclut pas d'envoyer d'autres chars de
combat dans le futur les Forces
canadiennes en possèdent 82 mais Ottawa
ne veut pas dire combien son fonctionnel
on en voit ce qui est finalement
il ne reste plus rien pour nous donc le
Canada vraiment besoin de de faire un
envoi puis de l'autre côté en même temps
racheter les nouvelles ressources pour
garder nos forces prêtes et le Canada
doit respecter ses propres engagements
militaires comme son déploiement
Lettonie pour la défense collective de
l'OTAN cette brigade va être encore
recommandée par un officier canadien et
ils auront besoin de léopard aussi
la machine à propagande c'est activée
les charges occidentaux sont qualifiées
de primitifs mais en même temps le
Kremlin laisse planer la menace d'une
escalade c'est selon moi du bluff que
c'est du chantage pour essayer de
d'empêcher sa fournisseur d'armes
supplémentaire mais qui a pas réel
considération terme le président
ukrainien est reconnaissant envers ses
alliés mais demande déjà de nouvelles
armes
comme des missiles à longue portée et
des avions de chasse la ministre de la
Défense préfère rester vague sur la
suite des choses
nous continuons de chercher qu'est-ce
que nous pouvons faire pour l'Ukraine la
ministre de la défense reste prudente
concernant les engagements futurs de son
gouvernement l'inventaire et les moyens
d'Ottawa sont limités l'apport peut
paraître symbolique à l'évidence c'est
le mieux que le Canada puisse faire pour
le moment ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada